Wouh !
Aïe ! Je me suis coupé !
Je me suis coupé contre le truc en bois !
Ne faites jamais Bruce Lee
chez vous !
Voilà, on voit la petite peau qui pend, c'est agréable.
Bon, comme vous l'aurez compris
d’après ce mouv extraordinaire,
aujourd'hui c'est une foire au question
alors on y va.
Je vous ai comme d'habitude demandé sur
Twitter
de me poser toutes vos questions
avec le #SqueezieQuestion.
Alors
*squeezie lit la question* (A quand une video « on essaye des objets étranges #4 »)
Ecoute, c'est marrant que tu dises ça, parce qu'il a pas
longtemps, j'ai parlé à Mcfly et Carlito
et je leur ai dit "les gars, j'ai hâte qu'on ouvre de nouveau des objets what the fuck".
Ce à quoi ils m'ont répondu :
"Nous aussi, à condition qu'on ne mette pas le feu à ton studio, parce qu'on est quand même papa, nous, contrairement à toi."
Je me suis donc énervé, étant donné que
je suis papa d'un merveilleux chien
qui a fraîchement eu 1 an
JOYEUX ANNIVERSAIRE NATSU
il est pas là aujourd'hui je suis dégoûté,
bref je divague.
J'aimerais en tourner une rapidement  à la rentrée,
pour être très franc avec vous, mais
je ne vais pas au Japon cet été,
donc il faut que je trouve un moyen d'acheter des objets
du Donkihote
sans aller au Japon, mais peut-être
qu'il y a d'autres sites qui vendent les même trucs et tout.
En tout cas, si vous, vous avez la chance d'aller au Japon,
bah kiffez bien et faites un petit saut au Donkihote,
vous allez trouver des objets marrants et incongrus,
vous allez rien en faire mais c'est pas grave.
*squeezie lit la question* Alors déjà y a beaucoup trop de questions qui commence par "à quand".
Vraiment les gens attendent trop de chose de moi, ça va pas du tout.
Bah...
Quand ils sortiront un nouvel album, voilà !
*squeezie lit la question* Bah franchement, elles me procurent un petit sentiment positif,
parce qu'elles me rappellent d'où je viens.
Et dans la vie, c'est important de ne pas oublier d'où l'on vient.
Mais à la fois de savoir où on va.
Et aussi de comprendre d'où ça vient !
*rires*
Non, surtout c'était un très bon souvenir,
parce que j'étais avec mon meilleur pote quand j'ai fait cette vidéo, et j'en ai gardé un souvenir mémorable, contrairement au parquet,
qui lui était plein d’œuf, c'était horrible, parce qu'en gros
on s'éclatait des œufs sur la tête pendant  toute la vidéo.
Mais ouais, c'était sympa ouais.
*squeezie lit la question*
Hoo...
Non...
Quel EP, quand?
*squeezie lit la question*
*le téléphone tombe*
*souffrant* Haaaaaaaa...
Je sais pas et je ne veux PAS savoir !
500€
Alors, j'ai la chance, grâce à vous, de recevoir tous les jeux presque gratuitement.
Les éditeurs me les envoient.
Du coup, vous me faites économiser beaucoup d'argent.
Au lieu de d'utiliser cet argent à bon escient,
le mettre de côté, le donner à ma maman,
j'en sais rien,
je lance Fortnite, et je le mets dans Fortnite.
Donc c'est horrible !
La solution au problème, c'est simple,
c'est que je dois travailler sur moi-même,
et demander à Epic Games
de m'offrir les skins !
*rires*
Comme ça je mettrai l'argent dans un autre jeu
mais je ne le garderai toujours pas.
*rires*
*squeezie lit la question*
Faire ce que je veux.
Faire vraiment ce que je veux.
Et puis essayer de "trantmettre" des...
de "trantmettre" ?
*voix off* "Wouah, j'ai vraiment besoin de vacances"
Ce que je préfère, c'est transmettre des choses positives,
peu importe ce que c'est, à vous.
C'est ça que j'aime bien, c'est essayer d'apprendre des trucs aux gens, si je peux, ou les divertir mais toujours dans le positif,
et pas dans le négatif.
Et contrairement à avant, je fais beaucoup plus attention à ce que je dis en vidéos, parce que des fois, sous l'excitation, sous le délire avec les potes,
on peut faire des blagues ou des trucs qui passent quand on est entre potes, mais qui passent pas quand on est regardé par des inconnus.
On peut transmettre des trucs tellement incroyables, tellement forts, qui peuvent faire du bien aux gens, qu'il faut en avoir conscience
et qu'il faut se pencher vers ça en fait.
Du bonheur, un moment divertissant, un souffle du nez, euh, un gros fou rire, j'en sais rien, mais c'est ça que j'aime bien, c'est ça que je préfère.
Et aussi de pas avoir de patron !
*squeezie lit la question*
Y'a pas longtemps, j'ai vécu un truc qui m'a fait me remettre en question, je suis allé à une soirée
d'une marque, je voulais pas y aller, mais bref, pour diverses raisons, j'y suis allé au final. Et j'ai absolument détesté tout ce qui m'entourait.
Vraiment ! Tout le monde se filmait, tout le monde était sur son 31,
c'était le concours de qui est le plus beau et qui pèse le plus. Et en fait, ça peut paraître con, mais ça m'a traumatisé !
*rires*
Attention, gros traumatisme, hein, waouh, la vie de de Babtou privilégié, c'est génial.
Mais je veux dire... Y'a des gens qui cherchent toute leur vie à aller à ce genre d'événement,
Mais vraiment, c'est nul !
Juste sortir avec mes potes, une aprem', aller au parc avec Natsu,
c'est tellement trop bien, tellement la meilleure chose que je peux faire en fait.
En fait des fois les trucs les plus simples que t'as sous le nez sont les meilleures choses que tu peux faire.
J'crois que ma place, c'est vraiment dans un parc avec mon chien, à ramasser ses cacas.
C'est là où que je me sens bien et vivant.
*rires*
*squeezie lit la question*
PUTAIN mais j'ai tellement envie ! Non, réellement, j'ai vraiment envie qu'il connaisse l'amour.
D'ailleurs, je le soupçonne d'être homosexuel, pour être franc avec vous, puisqu'il a régulièrement envie de
faire l'amour à son meilleur ami, ce qui me dérange absolument pas, mais je suis triste parce que du coup
ils pourront pas faire de petits ! Et des petits Natsu...
ce serait rigolo quand même.
*squeezie lit la question*
Bon, je vais vous expliquer un peu la vidéo des 10 millions, du coup,
mais en gros, je vais faire une surprise à plusieurs personnes à travers le monde
en allant toquer chez eux, sans qu'ils s'y attendent vraiment, et en les emmenant faire des
activités cool et en échangeant un moment avec eux vraiment, en "one to one" comme on dit,
parce que c'est ces moments là que je préfère,
c'est les moments où je peux parler à une personne, sans tout un bordel autour
juste lui et moi. Je peux découvrir ce qu'il fait dans la vie, ce qu'il aime, qui il est en fait.
Je crois que je vais vivre l'un des trucs les plus forts de toute ma vie, en fait.
Et puis voilà j'ai trop hâte ! Et ça sortira, je pense qu'il y a probablement plein de gens ont posé la question,
ça sortira en septembre, je sais pas encore la date, mais je vous la donnerai dans une future vidéo, voilà je fais une petite annonce pour ça.
Mais voilà, en tout cas, on va commencer par la tourner cette vidéo
avec un million d'abonnés de retard ! *rires* Mais c'est vous aussi, vous allez trop vite !
Vous vous abonnez tous !
*squeezie lit la question*
Eh bah du coup je viens de répondre à cette question. Vous avez vu ? J'ai bien géré mon déroulé de vidéo,
en tout cas c'est chouette, je suis vraiment talentueux aujourd'hui.
Non, en vrai, y'a un autre gros projet qui arrivera plus tard dans l'année,
j'en avais déjà parlé dans une vidéo avec Julfou et Théo. Flashback !
On faisait une réunion pour un gros projet qui sortira vers septembre, octobre, voilà. Inch Allah !
Je peux rien vous dire là-dessus pour le moment, mais ça va vraiment changer, de tout ce que j'ai pu faire comme gros projet,
mais j'ai pas spécialement le talent,
je pense, pour faire des courts-métrages.
Mais là, j'ai trouvé un truc qui est...
*squeezie hesite*
Entre 2 choses qui….
HAA ! Je peux rien vous dire ! C'est terrible !
Hé, déjà vous venez de grattez un peu le brief de la vidéo des 10 000 000,
Alors celui-là vous allez attendre hein, ho !
*squeezie lie la question *
Euh...Bon, je sais pas où tu as eu cette info...
Mais ouais... Depuis peu là ça va...
Ca va pas fort entre nous.
Peut-être je vais l'appeler pour en parler de vive voix, tu vois...
*Le téléphone vibre*
(Maxenss) Allo ?
Ouais... y'a un mec sur Twitter...
Y'a un mec sur Twitter qui a compris que ça allait plus trop entre nous...
*rires*
(Maxenss) Dis-moi tout Lucas !
En fait...je t'explique, je tourne un petite Foire Aux Questions...
et y'a un mec qui dit « j'ai vu que ça allait plus trop avec Maxenss.
Est-ce que c'est lié à l'éloignement dû au concert et tout »
Je vis un peu mal le fait que tu sois plus trop là à cause de ta tournée avec Vaisseau,
et puis voila, j'aimerais juste, peut être, un peu plus de SMS, tu vois, que tu m'envois...
et comme ça, peut-être c'est réglé quoi...
(Maxenss) Bah écoute, moi, je veux bien, je veux bien faire ça, mais...
(Maxenss) Moi je me sens bien comme ça, donc ce serait peut-être un peu me forcer quoi... Voilà.
*BIP BIP BIP*
*rires*
Maxenss, je t'aime, putain, deviens acteur !
*squeezie lit la question*
Ta question tombe à point, j'avais prévu de faire un bébé et de fonder une famille avec Kylian M'Bappé, en fait.
Très, très juste ! "Oh non, pas encore !"
Photo Twitter qui va très bien avec ton propose d'ailleurs !
Bah écoute, profitons de cette FAQ peut-être pour sensibiliser les gens !
Comme vous le savez peut-être, il y a énormément de gens qui abandonnent leurs animaux à l'approche des grandes vacances,
et du coup ils préfèrent oublier les responsabilités qu'ils ont accepté de prendre
en adoptant cet animal et en acceptant de recevoir son amour,
et les foutre à la rue, les lâcher au bord de la route, les attacher à un poteau
les envoyer au dessus des grilles de la SPA, bref, plein de trucs affreux.
Sachez, pour ceux qui veulent partir en vacances et qui n'ont aucun moyen de s'occuper de leurs animaux,
vous avez fait le choix de prendre un animal,
vous avez donc fait le choix de faire ce qu'on appelle des concessions,
à savoir « ah bah non, y'a mon animal, je ne peux pas partir en vacances, donc je l'abandonne pour partir. »
Bah non, mec !
Tu pars pas et tu t'occupes de ton animal à la place. C'est comme ça que ça marche !
Ou alors tu demandes à un ami de le garder, tu t'arranges pour partir en vacances à des dates différentes de tes amis,
ou alors tu le mets dans un hôtel pour chat ou chien, ça existe,
bref, tu trouves des solutions, et tu n'abandonnes pas ton animal !
Comme un gros fils de...
*squeezie lit la question*
Je sais pas, non...
En fait, y'a plein de gens qui m'ont dit « Ah, tu quittes le gaming, t'arrêtes définitivement. »
Bah non, déjà parce quand je vais jouer, ça va être surtout sur Twitch.
Je fais pas beaucoup de lives actuellement, mais j'ai un gros programme prévu à la rentrée,
avec des lives à heure fixe, et tout, mais je vous en parlerai au moment venu.
Du coup, je vais concentrer le gaming sur Twitch, et je vais concentrer le reste sur Youtube,
même s'il y aura encore des vidéos gaming sur Youtube.
En fait, je fais ce que j'aime, et en ce moment j'adore raconter des histoires,
parler de sujets qui me font marrer,
faire des vidéos avec les potes sur des trucs divers et variés,
faire des concepts hors du studio, faire des musiques...
Du coup, en fait, je suis vraiment mes envies,
et actuellement, mes jeux vidéos font un peu moins partie de mes envies,
que le reste, par rapport à avant. Et c'est bien,
ça montre que j'arrive à me renouveler, à m'amuser, en faisant d'autres trucs, c'est chouette.
Mais effectivement, je pense qu'il y aura toujours un peu moins de gaming sur ma chaîne que par rapport à 2014 ou 2015,
où là, y'avait que ça, mais bon !
A côté de ça, y'a du Twitch, enfin y'aura du Twitch à la rentrée, par rapport à 2014, 2015,
donc vous aurez quand même votre petite dose de jeux vidéos !
*squeezie lit la question*
Ouais !
*buzzer* La Mer Morte !
(Julien Lepers) Oui, oui, ah oui, oui !
*applaudissements* C'est moi !
*squeezie lit la question*
Oh, il négocie ! « Allez, juste pour le souvenir ! Baba ! Ouais ! »
Comme un gars le dit si bien en dessous, « Ce serait cool en effet mais je pense que pour lui c'est du passé. »
En fait, ouais, c'est vraiment du passé, c'est vraiment des trucs que j'ai fait à une époque, je l'ai déjà dit dans une autre FAQ,
mais, même les trucs que j'ai fait récemment, les threads, les théories du complot, et tout,
j'espère que dans un ou deux ans, même avant si ça se trouve, je ferai autre chose que ça en fait.
Pour continuer à prendre autant de plaisir dans ce que je fais, et que vous continuiez à adhérer au truc, en fait,
parce que justement ça avance, ça évolue, ça change, et c'est plaisant !
Alors... Hou là ! Alors là, on a 8 questions en une !
*squeezie lit la question*
Non, pas assez.
En vrai, j'aimerais toujours dormir plus que ce que je dors.
*squeezie lit la question*
Alors, normalement, je mange pas le matin, parce que j'ai pas faim, mais récemment... Voilà !
Je me mets des petits Special K, dans du lait d'amande. Voilà. Est-ce que c'est bien ou pas ? Je sais pas.
Mais ça me fait du bien à moi.
*squeezie lit la question*
Alors, je me suis à boire pas mal d'eau, y'a pas très longtemps, mais y'a pas très longtemps, je me suis mis à en boire moins qu'il y a pas très... * rires*
C'est la pire réponse !
*squeezie lit la question*
*rires* Bah... Je manque un peu d'eau, voilà, donc éventuellement, si tu veux me livrer des fois un ou deux packs d'eau, tu peux y'a pas de soucis.
Bah j'adore aussi ce concept, j'adore raconter des histoires en ce moment,
j'ai toujours aimé raconter des histoires, en fait, mais j'avais pas grand-chose à raconter,
à part dans les vidéos anecdotes où je raconte plein de trucs qui me sont arrivés.
Mais du coup, les threads, c'est des histoires que j'aime et j'adore les remanier un peu à ma sauce,
et vous les raconter d'une manière qui me plait.
Et puis Clément ensuite au montage fait un travail formidable d'illustration,
donc ça donne un format assez cool, je trouve. En tous cas vous avez été très nombreux à me dire que ça vous plait de ouf,
donc je suis hyper content. J'espère continuer ce format pendant encore un petit moment, en essayant de pas trop en abuser non plus, en vrai.
Mais je crois que l'idée m'était venue avec le fameux thread sur le message vocal que j'avais trouvé exceptionnel,
et puis je me suis dit « Putain, mais en fait, je pourrais le raconter aux gens et leur faire vivre aussi le truc, ça peut être cool ! »
Alors j'ai rien inventé, à mon avis, je suis pas du tout le premier à faire ça, vraiment,
mais en tous cas, j'ai eu l'idée moi-même, même si d'autres gens l'avaient fait avant, je m'étais dit moi-même « Putain j'ai envie de raconter ce truc, quoi. »
Ca me fait plaisir, et à vous aussi.
*squeezie lit la question*
Oh, c'est un supplice. Les gens viennent, ils viennent me voir, ils font « Mec, j'adore ce que tu fais, c'est trop cool ! Continue ! »
Et je les regarde et je fais « Mec tu peux pas me dire ça, c'est abusé ! T'abuses de ouf ! » *rires*
Non, en vrai, les 95% du temps, c'est vraiment chouette.
Surtout maintenant, en fait, c'est beaucoup de gens, très posés, très matures, qui ne veulent pas m'embêter...
parce qu'ils savent que c'est la vie privée en dehors des vidéos,
mais qui veulent quand même me dire un tout petit mot, parce que ça leur fait plaisir de me le dire, et qu'ils ont l'occasion de le faire.
Y'a juste quelque fois, où effectivement, tu as des hordes de 14 personnes qui arrivent en gueulant,
qui s'en battent les couilles, que tu sois seul ou accompagné ça change rien.
Là, j'avoue, c'est un moment un peu plus délicat.
Mais est-ce que je peux leur en vouloir d'être contents de me voir en vrai alors qu'ils ne s'y attendaient pas ?
Bah non !
Et puis il y a l'effet de groupe !
Moi j'avoue, si je vois un mec, je m'attendais pas à le voir en vrai, je suis avec mes potes, je vais devenir un ouf !
En vrai, non, y'a vraiment très peu de désavantages. Le seul vrai désavantage qu'il y a, c'est pas ça du tout.
C'est quand un livreur a ton numéro et en profite un peu derrière !
Ca c'est chiant ! *rires*
*squeezie lit la question*
*grognements* J'y pense !
On parlait justement de prendre en compte ce que ça implique de prendre un animal,
et avoir un deuxième chien, c'est pas comme un deuxième chat, où juste tu mets une deuxième litière.
tu mets une deuxième gamelle et tu t'en bats les couilles,
Là, mec, c'est sortir avec 2 laisses, avoir l'oeil sur 2 chiens
quand tu les mets sans laisse dans le parc...
Enfin je trouve que c'est une grosse implication, donc oui, je pense prendre un deuxième chien, mais non pas maintenant.
*squeezie lit la question*
C'est horrible, j'aime pas faire ça !
Mais, en gros, j'étais en...
J'ai dit "j'aime pas faire ça !" et puis je suis si vite passé à l'étape où je raconte l'anecdote, c'est horrible !
Je descendais d'un train en Suisse, pour aller prendre à manger.
C'était en revenant du ski, en revenant de Crans-Montana, on était parti avec les potes là-bas, c'était cool.
Et en revenant on avait un changement à faire, en fait, on était encore en Suisse.
Pendant le changement on décide d'aller prendre un truc dans un fast-food.
Et au fast-food, y'a un mec qui me reconnait et qui est très insistant.
Bah, je parle avec lui, le temps que je suis au MacDo, puis, en partant... Il me suit !
Il marche à côté de moi, il continue de me parler, et je lui dit « Mec, j'ai mon train dans 5 minutes, je suis désolé, je dois accélérer ! »
Il fait « OK, pas de soucis ! » et hop il se met à marcher plus vite !
Et à toujours continuer à côté de moi de me parler !
Jusque là, rien de gênant, sauf qu'en fait il me disait qu'il était rappeur, qu'il voulait faire un album de rap et qu'il voulait faire un feat avec moi.
Qui veut faire un feat avec Squeezie ? *rires*
Mais quelle sorte de rappeur es-tu ?
J'arrive devant mon wagon, il est là quoi, c'est-à-dire que le mec m'a suivi, vraiment, c'était loin le fast-food,
ensuite, je rentre dans le wagon et il va pour rentrer.
Et là les autres lui ont dit « Mec ! Calme, quoi ! Tranquille ! » Et il était hyper insistant et ça m'avait vraiment brusqué.
Mais bon, il était pas méchant, dans le fond, il était pas du tout méchant.
En fait, il était pas hyper net. Donc j'avais peur qu'il fasse : « On fait un feat ? » Que je réponde : « Bah non, en fait, je fais pas trop de musique. »
Et hop qu'il me plante, comme ça, hop le petit coup de couteau ! Comme ça !
Non, j'extrapole, mais on n'était pas loin de ça, vraiment.
*squeezie lit la question*
En fin d'année ! Très bonne question !
J'ai trop hâte, on va refaire un cache-cache géant, vers fin novembre, mi-décembre, un truc comme ça.
La première vidéo a extrêmement bien marché, j'ai reçu même beaucoup de messages de gens du Youtube Game pour me dire « Mec, c'était trop bien cette vidéo. »
Des messages de vous, j'en parle même pas. Y'a eu énormément de "J'aime" de commentaires... Voilà, vous avez adoré la vidéo,
et vous me l'avez montré, et vous l'avez surtout montré à Honor qui sponsorisait la vidéo,
parce que faire un cache-cache de cette manière, ça coûte de l'argent mec !
C'est pas pour rien qu'on ne peut pas le faire en vidéo !
Du coup, ils ont dit oui, pour une deuxième épisode, lors de la sortie du prochain Honor,
Alors voilà, merci à vous, bravo, vous les avez convaincu, c'est grâce à vous !
J'ai trop hâte ! Mon gars ! J'ai des idées de cachettes... Ca va être trop bien !
Les amis, c'est la fin de cette Foire Aux Questions, j'ai répondu à beaucoup de trucs...
y'a eu beaucoup de premier degré, bah au moins vous aurez appris pas mal de choses.
C'est vraiment dans ses vidéos là où je me lâche pour vous dire plein de trucs que je ressens, que je pense.
C'est juste un peu moins drôle que les autres, mais bon, ça reste quand même divertissant... J'espère !
Bref, j'ai encore quelques trucs à vous dire, mais je ferai une vidéo pour l'occasion.
Une vidéo bonus avant de partir en vacances, pour vous dire tout ça, y'a plein de bonnes choses.
Parce que tout n'est pas encore exactement prêt, je veux pas dire de bêtises.
Mais bon, bref ! Y'a plein de trucs cool qui vont arriver à la rentrée, plein de trucs qui me motivent et qui me font kiffer,
qui font que je continue à faire ce que je fais, du moins que je continue à le faire avec autant de plaisir !
J'espère que vos vacances se passent très très bien,
moi elles vont bien se passer, ce sera plus en août.
Merci pour tout, je vous aime, et je vous dis à bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo,
plus amusante, mais avec un cœur un peu moins ouvert.
Pire morale, je savais pas quoi faire... Bref, allez vas-y ! Allez, à bientôt !
Oh, j'ai pas ouvert ça !
A bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo ! *musique*